Tradutor: Maurício Kakuei Tanaka
Revisor: Custodio Marcelino
Um anjo me disse que podemos
ser deus de nós mesmos
e dar um rumo na nossa vida.
Vocês são o que vocês escolheram ser?
Vocês hoje aqui são
o que vocês escolheram ser?
Qual foi o exato momento em que você
escolheu ser o que você é hoje?
Eu morei na rua com a minha mãe
quando eu era pequenininha,
e eu fui obrigada a ser forte,
sobreviver só com a ajuda da minha mãe.
Eu fui forte naquele momento.
Quando menina, não tive opção.
Tive que ser forte e crescer assim.
Um belo dia,
eu fui convidada pra ir pra Alemanha.
Eram passagens gratuitas.
Me chamaram pra ir pra Alemanha.
Fiquei superfeliz.
Tirei o passaporte,
fiz o que tinha que fazer.
De repente,
eu estava na minha cozinha,
e eu ouvi assim, sem cerimônia nenhuma,
sem massagem:
"Você não vai mais comigo
pra Alemanha, Eliane.
Só vão homens".
E eu disse: "E daí?"
"Você não vai."
Eu falei assim: "Como?
Eu já tirei o passaporte;
já vi quem vai cuidar das crianças;
já fiz a mala; e agora eu não vou?"
"Não, você não vai."
Eu falei assim:
"Tá bom".
Ele me disse assim:
"Você não vai brigar?"
Eu disse: "Não".
"Você vai me trair?"
"Não."
"Você vai embora?"
Falei: "Não".
"Vai lá.
Vai pra Alemanha.
Quando você voltar, estará tudo melhor
do que o que você deixou aqui."
Dali pra frente, naquele exato momento,
eu decidi ser advogada,
nesse exato momento,
e esse exato momento me trouxe até aqui.
Nesse momento, quando decidi ser advogada,
eu não podia mais
pensar em entrar à esquerda
ou entrar à direita.
Eu não podia engravidar,
pra fugir da minha missão.
Eu não podia ficar doente,
pra não perder o meu foco,
e não podia brigar com o meu companheiro,
que estava fazendo coisas
que me desagradavam,
pra não sair da minha reta.
A partir do momento
em que eu decidi ser advogada,
os ventos só me trouxeram
grandes desafios,
e eu encaro os grandes desafios,
porque a gente é o que a gente quer ser.
A gente faz o que a gente quer fazer.
Mas aí, vocês podem me perguntar:
"Mas, se é fácil assim,
por que existem pessoas
que ficam dando voltas
em torno do seu próprio rabo?
Por que existem pessoas que nunca vencem?
Por que existem pessoas que passam
a vida sem o amor verdadeiro;
que passam a vida sem um bom trabalho;
que passam a vida
sem conseguir fazer uma viagem;
que passam a vida infeliz,
como se tivessem recebido uma droga;
que passam uma vida drogada?
Existem pessoas que passam a vida
girando em torno do seu próprio rabo,
porque têm medo de dizer: "Eu quero".
As pessoas dizem:
"Eu desejo", "Eu gostaria".
Elas não dizem: "Eu quero".
As pessoas têm medo de encarar
o tamanho das escolhas que fizeram.
Eu passei sete anos estudando.
Eu não ia a casamentos,
velórios, shoppings,
enterros.
Eu não ia...
a cabeleireiro, manicure,
e, no final, nem à depilação eu ia.
(Risos)
Graças a Deus, acabou.
Você pode dizer:
"Mas, sete anos
fazendo uma coisa que você
nem sabe se vai dar certo?"
Eu estava fazendo o que eu queria.
Eu estava fazendo o que eu escolhi.
E, se isso, depois de sete anos,
não desse certo,
eu ia mudar o rumo,
ia dormir o sono dos justos,
porque eu fiz o máximo;
eu dei o meu máximo;
eu fiz tudo o que eu poderia fazer.
E aí, eu ia fazer
outra coisa, feliz da vida.
A gente tem que ter coragem
de encarar as nossas escolhas,
tem que ter coragem de assumir
o tamanho das nossas escolhas.
Eu acredito,
piamente, que, a partir do momento
em que a gente tem um desejo,
e esse desejo é verdadeiro,
ele é materializado,
e toda a nossa vida
é direcionada para esse desejo.
Então, não adianta a gente ficar
virando à esquerda e à direita
nas ruas, nas avenidas das nossas vidas,
porque vai ficar a vida inteira
como se tivesse recebido uma droga.
Quando a gente faz o que a gente quer,
pode ser um, dois, três, sete anos,
a gente faz e faz feliz,
mas, pra isso, a gente
tem que ter coragem de dizer:
"Eu quero".
Assim, eu encerro dizendo pra vocês
que a realidade é uma mera ilusão,
ainda que bem persistente,
como disse Albert Einstein.
Muito obrigada.
(Aplausos) (Vivas)